DOCTORS MAKE.
>> HE WAS MY BEST FRIEND.
I'M SORRY.
>> Reporter: CHRIS ALLISON LOST
THE LOVE OF HER LIFE IN 2018.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND TROY WERE AT
HOME ON A SUMMER SATURDAY NIGHT,
WHEN HE STARTED HAVING
DIFFICULTY BREATHING.
HAD THIS HAPPENED BEFORE OR --
>> NO.
THE FIRST TIME.
FIRST TIME.
>> Reporter: TROY, WHO SUFFERED
FROM DIABETES, SAID TO CALL FOR
AN AMBULANCE.
>> THEY CHECKED HIS VITALS.
AND HE SAID HIS SUGAR WAS A
LITTLE HIGH.
HE SAID I THINK I'M GOING TO
TAKE HIM OVER FOR A PRECAUTION.
I WAS, LIKE, ARE YOU OKAY WITH
THAT?
HE SAID, YEAH.
>> Reporter: IT WOULD BE THE
COUPLE'S FINAL CONVERSATION.
TROY WAS TRANSPORTED A FEW MILES
AWAY TO MOUNT CARMEL WEST
HOSPITAL IN COLUMBUS, OHIO.
ACCORDING TO MEDICAL REPORTS
FROM THE PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEYS,
TROY SUFFERED AT LEAST TWO HEART
ATTACKS IN THE ER.
THE CHAPLIN SAT WITH CHRIS.
TROY WAS TAKEN TO THE ICU, WHERE
THE NIGHT SHIFT DOCTOR WAS
WILLIAM HUSSEL.
>> HE SAYS I'M 99.9% SURE THERE
IS NO BRAIN ACTIVITY THAT HE IS
BRAIN DEAD.
HIS ORGANS ARE SHUTTING DOWN.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE HIM SOMETHING
TO MAKE HIM COMFORTABLE.
>> Reporter: A SHORT TIME LATER,
THE 44-YEAR-OLD HUSBAND AND
STEPFATHER WAS DEAD.
>> IT JUST WASN'T ADDING UP.
>> Reporter: MONTHS AFTER HIS
DEATH, CHRIS SAYS SHE GOT A CALL
FROM THE HOSPITAL, SAYING HE HAD
BEEN GIVEN AN OVERDOSE.
TROY RECEIVED 1,000 MICROGRAMS
OF FENTANYL FROM DR. HUSSEL.
>> THEY SAID THEY'RE GOING TO
GIVE HIM SOMETHING TO MAKE HIM
COMFORTABLE.
HE DIDN'T SAY 1,000 MICROGRAMS
OF FENTANYL AND HE'LL BE DEAD
BEFORE YOU ENTERED THE ROOM,
THAT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION.
>> Reporter: THEY TOLD CNN IN A
STATEMENT WHAT HAPPENED WAS
TRAGIC AND WE MADE A NUMBER OF
CHANGES DESIGNED TO PREVENT THIS
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN IN OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM.
AN INVESTIGATION WAS INITIATED
BY MOUNT CARMEL AND FOUND THE
DOCTOR ALLEGEDLY ADMINISTERS
DEADLY DOSES OF PAINKILLERS TO
AT LEAST 25 PATIENTS.
IN 2018 HE WAS FIRED, AND THE
FOLLOWING YEAR HIS MEDICAL
LICENSE SUSPENDED BY THE STATE
OF OHIO.
>> IT IS OUR SINCERE HOPE THE
FAMILIES OF THESE VICTIMS WILL
FIND SOLACE BY THE STATE OF OHIO
HOLDING THE DOCTOR ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HIS DEVIOUS CONDUCT.
>> Reporter: PROSECUTORS CHARGED
HUSSEL WITH 25 COUNTS OF FIRST
DEGREE MURDER, 11 OF THOSE HAVE
SINCE BEEN DISMISSED.
HE HAS PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
>> WILLIAM WAS A COMPASSIONATE
DOCTOR, AND THAT'S WHY HE'S
STANDING TRIAL FOR MURDER,
BECAUSE OF HIS COMPASSION, NOT
BECAUSE OF SOME CRIMINAL ACT
THAT HE ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED.
>> Reporter: HIS ATTORNEY SAYS
EACH OF HUSSEL'S 14 PATIENTS WAS
NEAR THE END OF LIFE, AND THE
DOCTOR WAS PREVENTING NEEDLESS
SUFFERING, KNOWN AS COMFORT
CARE.
>> THIS IS THE VERY FIRST TIME
COMFORT CARE IS ON TRIAL.
AND I DON'T WANT A PROSECUTOR
TELLING MY DOCTOR OR ME THAT MY
LOVED ONE HAS TO DIE IN PAIN.
IT IS WRONG.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
IT IS NOT THEIR BUSINESS.
>> Reporter: THERE IS NO
STANDARDIZED DOSING FOR COMFORT
CARE MEDICATIONS WHEN A PATIENT
IS CLOSE TO DEATH.
IT IS DOCTOR DISCRETION AND IT
IS BASED ON THE ENTIRE MEDICAL
RECORD.
HUSSEL IS FACING 14 LIFE TERMS,
BUT THEY -- THE PATIENTS HAD
MULTIPLE MEDICAL ISSUES.
I MEAN, THE GENTLEMAN THAT WE
PROFILED, TROY ALLISON, HAD MANY
MEDICAL ISSUES THAT WERE DIRE.
HE WAS CLOSE TO DEATH.
SO TO PROVE THAT HE CAUSED THE
DEATH BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT FOR THE
PROSECUTION.
BUT THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THE FUTURE OF COMFORT CARE
MEDICATION.
ONE WAY OR